I'm super excited to be joined by mr.
wit of Fort Bend tutoring YouTube
channel here we're gonna be going
through six questions alternating one at
a time talking about how to graph these
rational functions you're gonna be
learning how to find the asymptotes
whether it's up slant asymptotes or
horizontal asymptotes how to find the
vertical asymptotes the X intercepts Y
intercepts how to do sign analysis how
to get a good sketch of your graph let's
jump into number one if you want the
free worksheet it's down in the
description below I'll have a link there
for you but you can also pause the video
if you like number one we're looking at
f of X equals 3x squared plus 4x minus 4
over the quantity x squared minus 1 now
when you're graphing rational functions
the first thing that you're going to
want to do is factor it as much as you
possibly can and the reason we do that
is because if we have factors in the
numerator and the denominator that
cancel out right then that tells us that
there's going to be a hole in the graph
meaning like a removable discontinuity
like so so here if we factor the
numerator you can see that factors to 3x
and let's see this looks like it's going
to be plus 2 and minus 2 okay so now
that we have it completely factored f of
X you can think of as like your Y value
what we want to do is look for those
factors there's nothing that cancels a
numerator and denominator so you don't
have any holes in the graph the next
thing I would do is I would set the
denominators factors equal to 0 to find
your vertical asymptotes so if we do
that we just say X plus 1 equals 0
subtract 1 from both sides and same
thing here if we say X minus 1 equals 0
add 1 to both sides you can see that
your vertical asymptotes are going to be
at negative 1 and positive 1 and so
let's go ahead and sketch those in right
now so x equals negative 1 I'd like to
do it as I'm working through the problem
so I can kind of see it coming together
ok the next step is to analyze do we
have a slant asymptote a horizontal
asymptote and you know what would that
asymptote be well what you want to do is
you want to look at the highest power
term in the numerator this is like a 1
because 1 times anything is itself and
that highest power term in the
denominator and if it's a tie such as in
this one you can see x squared and x
squared what you get is you get the
ratio of the coefficients in front of
those two terms so it's going to be y
equals 3 over 1 or you can say Y is
equals with
so let's go ahead and sketch in that
horizontal asymptote now you might be
saying Mario well what happens if the
numerators power is greater than the
denominators well in that case you're
going to have a slant asymptote and
we'll come across those in this video
what happens if the denominators degree
is higher than the numerator say this
was like a 5 and then what happens is
you have y equals 0 or the x-axis is
going to be your horizontal asymptote
okay so the next step now we've got our
asymptotes we want to find out where
does it cross the x axis and the y axis
now there's a couple different ways to
do this one way to do it is you can make
a table like so you can say if I put 0
in for X I'm gonna be solving for the y
intercepts if I put 0 in for Y you're
gonna be solving for the X intercepts so
you set that opposite variable equal to
0 so let's go ahead and put 0 in for X
if we put 0 in for X you can see that
all these terms that have an X in them
they're gonna cancel out so you're just
gonna end up with negative 4 over
negative 1 which is positive 4 so that
means that it's gonna cross the y axis
at 1 2 3 positive 4 right there okay now
if we set the Y value equal to 0 to find
the x intercepts what I want you to
realize is the only way that this is
going to be equal to 0 is if the
numerator of the fraction is equal to 0
and not simultaneously the denominator
so what I mean by that is like if you
were to take this these factors in the
numerator set them equal to 0 those are
going to be your X intercepts because
say for example if I set X plus 2 equal
to 0 we get negative 2 right well you
can see if I put negative 2 in here
that's going to make this 0 0 times
anything is 0 these are not going to be
0 so you're gonna get 0 over something
that's not 0 which is equal to 0 so
that's kind of just like a shortcut set
the numerator is equal to zero to find
the x-intercepts so we get negative 2
which is right here and if we set this
equal to 0 we're going to get 2/3 so
that's going to be right here just a
little shy of one so now we've got some
key points or y-intercepts and X
intercepts we've got our asymptotes the
last thing we want to do is to find out
you know what happens when you approach
these vertical asymptotes from the right
side and from the left side because you
can cross a horizontal asymptote
you can cross a slant asymptote you
cannot cross
a vertical asymptote because if you did
say for example if it came out to
negative one then you would be dividing
by 0 which is undefined right so what
happens when you're approached those
vertical asymptotes the graph see
they're gonna turn up towards positive
eight or it's gonna turn down towards a
negative infinity what I'm going to show
you now is sign analysis so you analyze
the signs so what I mean by that is
let's start over here on the Left see
we're approaching negative one we're
getting really close to negative one
from this side okay from the left side
say for example I was to put in negative
one point one okay so if I put in
negative one point one I'm gonna put it
into this factored form here negative
one point one is gonna make this
negative three point three minus two
which is negative five point three now
I'm not so concerned about the number as
I am with the sign so that came out to a
negative a negative one point one plus
two gives you a positive number okay and
then over here a negative one point one
plus one is a negative number and
negative one point one minus one is a
negative number so we have a negative
times a positive which is a negative a
negative times a negative is a positive
and a negative divided by a positive we
know is a negative number so that tells
us we're approaching from this side here
negative one point one it's going down
towards negative infinity so our graphs
gonna look like that it's gonna
gradually approach this horizontal
asymptote right now let's see what
happens when you approach it from this
side and the vertical asymptotes say for
example you put in negative 0.9 okay so
we're getting really close from this
side well if I put a negative point nine
that's gonna make this factor here
negative okay and then we've got
negative point nine plus two is going to
be positive and then we have negative
point nine plus one which is positive
and negative point nine minus one is a
negative so you can see we're getting a
negative times a positive which is a
negative and positive times a negative
which is a negative and a negative
divided by a negative which is a
positive which tells us that this graph
is going up towards positive infinity
now if you don't like this method you're
saying Mario that sounds kind of
confusing you can just plug in values
like actually take that negative one
point one or that negative point nine
and get an actual number and plot that
number and then you'll be able to tow
there it's going up or down this is a
little bit quicker way just analyzing
the signs okay so we know what's going
up this way let's see what happens we
approach to this vertical asymptote from
the left side here
well this was two-thirds let's maybe put
in like the positive 0.9 so almost 2-1
but not quite so if we put in positive
0.9 that would make this a positive
group here a positive factor 0.9 plus
the two is gonna give us a positive 0.9
plus 1 is gonna be positive point 9
minus 1 is going to be negative so we
have a positive divided by a negative
which is a negative which tells us that
this is going down so now we can see
what's happening with this graph it
looks like it's crossing the x-axis
there it's crossing the y-axis there and
then it's going and approaching those
two asymptotes now the last thing we
want to do is when I approach this
vertical asymptote from this side so for
example if I put in like positive one
point one just a little bit to the right
of this vertical asymptote one point one
would make this positive one point one
plus to make that positive one point one
is positive one point one minus one is
positive positive divided by a positive
is a positive that tells us is going up
towards positive infinity and then it
gradually approaches that horizontal
asymptote now if you want you can plot
additional points you know to get a a
better sketch but this is a pretty good
idea what our graph is gonna look like
thanks Mario and problem number two we
have f of x equals negative four divided
by x squared plus two one of the first
things I like to do when sketching a
rational function is to analyze the
equation notice that in the denominator
here we have a quadratic expression this
x squared plus two that's important
because I want to take every opportunity
I can to factor the original function
completely so when we look at the
denominator here this binomial of x
squared plus two this is similar to the
form of a sum of squares we're just not
factorable using real numbers
so therefore when it comes time for me
to identify what the domain of this
function is X is such that X is in the
set of all real numbers so that means
that we can pick any value for x that we
choose in regards to choosing a value
for X to plug into this function because
the domain is the set of all real
numbers we're not gonna have a vertical
asymptote here because as you recall in
order to find the vertical asymptote
you'll need to set the denominator equal
to zero and if we would have set x
squared plus two equal to zero
solving for this we'll be subtracting
two to both sides and you end
with x squared equals to negative 2 now
you know that squaring any value will
give you a positive result right so if
you tried to go any further you would
end up with an imaginary number here
when you try to solve for x and due to
that you're not going to have a vertical
asymptote so the correct answer for the
vertical asymptote is none you won't
have me now when it comes to the
horizontal asymptote remember that
anytime the degree of the numerator is
less than that degree in the denominator
and in this case you can say that our
degree in the numerator is zero whereas
our degree in the denominator is two so
due to that your horizontal asymptote
will be y equals zero y equals zero and
keep in mind that this is where the
function will be gravitating towards
whether you're approach negative
infinity or positive infinity but there
are cases where the horizontal asymptote
can be violated whereas if we had a
vertical asymptote then the function
will never touch the vertical asymptote
but keep in mind that you can have
situations where the horizontal
asymptote can be crossed in other words
it can be touched and if you ever want
to test to see if the original function
will touch the horizontal asymptote just
set the original function equal to that
horizontal and see if you can get a
value of x that is a real number the
next thing is the x intercept well we're
not gonna have an x intercept in this
case the reason for this is because in
order to find the x intercept you simply
set the numerator equal to zero and of
course if I say that negative 4 equals
to zero well that's a false statement
right so due to that fact you're not
going to have an x intercept so let's
move on to finding the y intercept of
course what we're doing is just trying
to flesh out all of the information that
we can identify from the original
function and part of that is identifying
the y intercept in order to find the y
intercept you simply plug in 0 for all
the X's in the original function and
then simplify so that means that will be
actually finding F of 0 so we'll have
negative 4 divided by 0 squared plus 2
which gives us negative 4 divided by 2
which gives you a result of negative 2
and if you were to write this value as
an ordered pair you would say that the y
intercept is 0 negative 2 so before we
move on ok I always prefer to box up my
it just clarifies where I can locate all
the important information that I've
gathered thus far and I like to use a
red box so my domain once again is all
real numbers for the values of X I do
not have a vertical asymptote I know
that my horizontal asymptote is y equals
0 and I don't have an exersaucer and we
found out that our y intercept that
point is 0 negative 2 so let's continue
on with our process for sketching this
rational function now on this page we're
going to actually flesh out and grab the
actual rational function so what I want
to start out with is the fact that we
know that we have a horizontal asymptote
of y equals 0
aka the x-axis so I know that my
rational function is going to gravitate
toward this line y equals 0 especially
as we move to negative infinity as well
as to positive infinity along the x axis
so due to that we can definitely say
that our end behavior is going to be as
X approaches negative infinity Y
approaches 0 and then as X approaches
positive infinity Y will approach 0 so
these are things that we know about the
function from the end behavior being as
though as you plug in increasingly
smaller X values into our function this
value once squared the denominator is
going to become huge in fact the
denominator will approach positive
infinity so because of that the negative
4 divided by positive finding will give
you a value very very close to zero the
same thing applies when you plug in
positive values so for instance if I
plug in 10 or 100 this denominator will
get increasingly larger as we approach
positive infinity and therefore the
overall value of this being as though
that denominator being large going into
negative 4 is going to be increasingly
smaller and smaller as a value and
therefore will approach zero so we will
definitely keep those things in mind we
already know that we have a y-intercept
of 0 negative 2 right and so what I want
to do is I want to plug in values that
are panning away from that zero value so
for instance I can plug in a value like
negative 1 or even I can plug
value like negative two and then we can
take this out further and plug in let's
say negative four and let's do the same
on the opposite side of zero so what I'm
doing here is I'm creating an XY chart
that I can use to graph my rational
function here and knowingly choosing
values that I know are in the domain of
our rational function here so we know
that our y intercept here is at zero
negative two
plug me in negative 4 we'll have F of
negative 4 equals to negative 4 divided
by the quantity of negative 4 squared
plus 2 this gives me negative 4 divided
by 16 plus 2 which gives me a result of
negative 4 a teens well that's negative
2/9 when we simplified right so we end
up with negative 2/9 here for our y
value a very small number indeed next
let's plug in negative 2 so we'll have F
of negative 2 equals 2 negative 4
divided by negative 2 squared plus 2 and
this equals to negative 4 divided by 4
plus 2 which is negative 4 6 and once
you simplify the negative 4 6 you'll end
up with negative 2/3 all right then when
you plug in negative 1 you're AB f of
negative 1 equals 2 negative 4 divided
by negative 1 squared plus 2 this gives
us negative 4 divided by 1 plus 2 so you
end up with negative 4/3 so negative 4/3
is what we end up with for y when we
plug in negative 1 into the original
function plugging in 1 you'll have 1
squared is 1 1 plus 2 is 3 this is also
going to give you negative 4/3 okay
plugging in 2 2 squared plus 2 is 6 in
the denominator right well that gives
you negative 2/3 again and then finally
when you plug in 4 you have 4 squared is
16 16 plus 2 is 18 again so let's gives
you negative 2/9 so we actually have
some symmetry here and we have proven
that we have symmetry about the y-axis
something that we could have proven from
the beginning algebraically so let's
start applying our points with negative
4 negative 2/9 so that negative 4 you
have negative 1 there 2 negative 3
negative 4 and negative 2 ninths gonna
be almost to 0 so it's gonna be about
right there and then
you have negative two negative two
thirds negative one negative two and
then it's almost a negative one here and
then you'll have a point at negative one
negative one and one-third some negative
one negative one one-third will give us
a point right here
and then you're going to mirror that on
the opposite side of Y right so you'll
have a point at 1 and one 1/3 and then
you'll have a point at 2 negative 2/3
and then you'll have a point at 4
negative 2/9 and anything beyond that is
going to be getting increasingly closer
to 0 to the left and you'll be getting
increasingly closer to 0 to the right so
we'll do with these points as we'll go
ahead and make a sketch that looks just
like this little dip here and arrows on
both ends and there is the sketch of the
graph the final thing you may want to do
is look at the range of your function so
based on our sketch here we see that the
lowest point possible in this case it's
going to be negative 2 so your range is
going to be from negative 2 including
negative 2 to 0 so for your y-values you
can say that your range will be less
than 0 however will be greater than or
equal to negative 2 so written as a
compound inequality you can say that
your range or Y values we're going to be
between negative 2 and 0 including
negative 2 and that's problem number two
guys ok number three we have f of x
equals x squared plus 2x minus 3 divided
by the quantity X minus 2 this is an
interesting problem because notice how
the degree in the numerator is higher
than the degree of the highest power
term in the denominator okay and it's
higher by one which tells us that this
is going to be a slant asymptote okay
but first things first let's go ahead
and factor as much as we can so I always
like to do that step first it looks like
this is going to factor 2x plus 3x minus
1 all divided by X minus 2 and the
reason we do that is we want to see if
there's any factors that cancel
numerator and denominator if there are
we'll have holes in the graph this
particular problem doesn't have any of
those removable discontinuities or those
holes so the next thing I like to do is
look at the vertical asymptotes and we
can do that by setting the denominators
factors equal to 0 so if I say X mine
two equals zero add two to both sides x
equals two is going to be our vertical
asymptote right there okay now like we
said originally that you can see the
degree in the numerator is higher so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
synthetic division so if you need to
review your synthetic division but if
we're dividing by X minus 2 I'm going to
put positive 2 right here it was X plus
2 and I'm putting negative 2 here now
what you want to do is you want to make
sure your terms are in descending order
you're going to use the coefficients 1 x
squared 2x negative 3 if there's any
missing terms you want to put zeroes for
your place holders right so you drop
down that first number and multiply on
the diagonal add straight down multiply
on the diagonal add straight down and so
now you can see we started with x
squared when you do the synthetic
division it goes down by one degree so
we have 1 X plus 4 plus 5 over X minus 2
this is your remainder you put over your
divisor now as X gets larger and larger
this term here this remainder here goes
to 0 so you don't have to worry about
that remainders our slant asymptote is
just going to be y equals 1 X plus 4 so
let's go ahead and put that on our graph
y intercept of 4 1 2 3 4 it's crossing
right here it has a slope of 1 which
means it's going to go like here at a 45
degree angle it's gonna cross right here
so we see if I can sketch this in
accurately for us like that okay so
that's our slant asymptote now the next
thing is we want to find out the X
intercepts and the y intercepts so to
find the y intercept where it crosses
the y axis since you're not going left
or right you're going to set the x value
equal to 0 if we put 0 in for X you can
see we get negative 3 over negative 2
which is 3 over 2 which is 1 and 1/2 or
1.5 so that tells us it's going to cross
right there at 1.5 now to find the
x-intercepts like we talked about in
example one you can just take the
numerators factors and set those equal
to zero so if I set X plus 3 equal to 0
I get negative 3 1 2 negative 3 if I set
X minus 1 equal to 0 and add 1 we're
going to get x equals positive 1 so it's
going to cross right there okay the only
thing left to do now is to analyze what
happens when you approach the vertical
asymptote for
left the vertical asymptote from the
right because remember you can't cross a
vertical asymptote the graph sees are
going to turn up towards positive
infinity so just kind of turn down
towards a negative infinity and here's
where I like to use the sign analysis so
for example let's say we're approaching
this x equals 2 from the left so I'm
going to put in 1.9 if I put in 1.9
that's going to make this positive 1.9
minus 1 is going to be a positive 1
point 9 minus 2 is going to be a
negative positive positive is a positive
divided by negative is going to be a
negative so that means that this is
going down towards negative infinity so
you can see this branch of the graph is
going to look something like that it's
going to gradually approach that slant
asymptote now from the right side let's
say I put in 2.1 just slightly to the
right of the vertical asymptote that's
going to make this positive positive
positive so a positive divided by a
positive is a positive
that means when we're approaching from
the right here it's gonna be going up
towards positive infinity and then it's
gonna be approaching your slant
asymptote so again you can plot
additional points if you want to get a
more accurate graph in calculus you're
gonna learn how to find out exactly
where these minimums and maximums are
where the graph bends but for purposes
of this video we've got a pretty good
sketch for problem before we'll be
sketching f of x equals x squared plus
3x plus 2 divided by x squared minus X
minus 2 we're presented with a rational
function like this guys you'll want to
go ahead and factor as much as possible
so you want to factor the numerator two
wanna factor the denominator so factor
our original function here we can
rewrite it as f of X equals two factors
of two that will add to give you three
or two and one so the numerator factors
into X plus 2 times X plus one then in
the denominator two factors that
multiply to give you 2 and then subtract
to give you the coefficient of one it's
two and one
however this time you'll end up with X
minus 2 times X plus one
notice that you have a reducible
rational function at this point meaning
that you have a factor that's identical
in the numerator in the denominator and
therefore because of this you're gonna
end up with a hole and it'll have a hole
where the factor X plus 1 would eat
to zero so what you'll do is in order to
find out the x value of that hole you'll
set the factor that we were able to
simplify to zero and solve for it and
you will find that x equals a negative
one and then to find the point where
this occurs in the graph you'll simply
plug in negative 1 into this reduced
form of our original function which is X
plus 2 divided by X minus 2 if I were to
plug in negative 1 into the numerator
negative 1 plus 2 is 1 negative 1 minus
2 gives your result of negative 3 so
that means that our hole will occur at
the point negative 1 negative 1 3 then
as far as your vertical asymptote is
concerned you want to go back to your
reduced factored form here this X plus 2
divided by X minus 2 and notice that we
only have one factor in the denominator
to set equal to 0 so that means that
once you identify a whole your whole
won't also be a vertical asymptote okay
so it's gonna be one or the other you're
either gonna have a factor that's a
vertical asymptote or you're going to
have a factor that's a hole so due to
that you'll set X minus 2 equal to 0 and
then solving for x you'll end up with
the vertical asymptote x equals 2 and of
course I like to read box it so we're
gonna be boxing up our hole you'll need
that and of course you'll need your
vertical asymptotes all right and might
as well keep up with your factored form
of the original rational function let's
move on the next thing we want to do is
identify the horizontal asymptote keep
in mind that any time the degree of the
numerator in this case it's 2 is
identical to the denominators degree
which is also 2 then what you can
essentially do is ignore all the rest of
the terms here so if I take my function
of f of X which equals to Y by the way
and this is going to be x squared plus
3x plus 2 all divided by x squared minus
X minus 2 and if you ignore all of the
lower degree terms then you'll end up
simplifying x squared divided by x
squared which equals to one right so
that means that our
horizontal asymptotes is why it was one
yeah that's an ugly one let's fix it
much better right so now we have our
horizontal asymptotes so using the
numerator of our simplified form here
this X plus 2 divided by X minus 2
you'll set the numerator equal to zero
and solve for so doing so you'll have x
equals to negative 2 as your x intercept
so it has a point you have negative 2 0
yeah
when it comes to the wine itself you
want to find out what f of 0 is so that
means that you're going to be plugging
in 0 and 2 your reduced rational
function so that means I'll have 0 plus
2 divided by 0 minus 2 so 2 divided by
negative 2 is negative 1 so as an
ordered pair your y-intercept is 0
negative 1 and so read that box it our
Ozona asymptote is y equals 1 our x
intercept is the point negative 2 0 and
your wife so is the point 0 negative 1
now let's recognize that since 2 is
undefined we'll want to find out values
to the left of 2 for instance 1 and 0
and also values to the right of 2 which
we can say are 3 & 4 now we already know
we have a y-intercept of 0 negative 1
right so that's that point and we also
know that we have an excess of at
negative 2 so we go ahead to depth 1
right here and we are so aware the fact
that we have a horizontal asymptote at 1
so let's go ahead and show that right
here we have a horizontal loved y equals
2y then the vertical asymptote was exit
was two to correct so this creates my
framework for my rational function then
I want to complete my XY chart plug me
in 1 in the numerator you'll have 3 over
negative 1 which simplifies to negative
3 then if I plug in 3 you'll have 5 over
1 which gives you 5 plugging in 4 you'll
end up with 6 over 2 and that gives you
3 okay so now with that along with the
fact that we have a hole at negative 1
negative 1/3 puts a hole
right there then you have your wine
except at zero negative one like so then
you have a point at 1 negative 3 so at 1
negative 3 and then across the vertical
asymptote if you have a point at 3 5 3
and 1 2 3 4 5 then you also have a point
at 4 3 1 2 3 4 and then up 3 all right
you should be aware that this form of
your rational function is similar to the
parent function f of X equals to 1 over
X which is normally like this all right
you can then graph the following
function like son you know whatever
looking like this to the right and
you're going to have that hole there so
make sure you're not going through
though the hole needs to be just that it
needs to be a hole in the graph guys and
that completes your sketch you'll say
that as X approaches negative infinity y
approaches 1 and as X approaches
positive infinity y approaches 1 so
that'll be the end behavior for problem
before as well as your sketch of the
rational function ok number 5 we have f
of X equals 2x over the quantity x
squared plus 3 now the first thing you
want to do like I say in the other
examples is you want to factor as much
as you can but this particular problem
you can't factor at all all right so the
next thing I like to do is I look like
to look at the vertical asymptotes so to
find the vertical asymptotes what you
want to do is you want to set that
denominator equal to zero or the factors
if you factored it set each factor equal
to zero so if I subtract 3 from both
sides and I take the square root to get
X by itself you see we can't take the
square of a negative number without
getting imaginary numbers so what that
tells us is is that there's not going to
be any vertical asymptotes in this
particular graph so that's very
interesting now the other thing that's
interesting about this problem is that
you see how the highest degree term in
the denominator see how that degree is
higher than the highest degree term in
the numerator when you have that
situation where the degree in the bottom
is higher than the degree in the top the
horizontal asymptote is going to be y
equals 0 which is right at the x AK
so I'm going to draw this a little bit
on a diagonal so it stands out from the
x-axis like so okay so we're just right
over here y equals zero that's our
horizontal asymptote
okay the next day I like to do we like
to go to the X intercepts and the y
intercepts
so to find the y intercept where it
crosses the y axis we put 0 in for X
because you're not going left or right
I put 0 in for X you can see we're going
to get 0 over 3 which is just 0 so our y
intercept is going to be right here at
the origin at 0 and if we want to find
the x intercept what you can do is you
can set the factors in the numerator
equal to 0 but if we set to X equal to 0
and divide both sides by 2 you can see
we're also getting 0 so it's crossing
the y axis and the x axis at the same
point right here at the origin so now
this point this is kind of interesting
because we don't have those vertical
asymptotes we just have this horizontal
asymptote and remember you might be
thinking yourself well Mario this is an
asymptote why is there a point right on
the asymptote well remember you can
cross a horizontal asymptote you can
cross the slant asymptote
you just can't cross a vertical
asymptote because then you'd be dividing
by 0 so the only thing really left for
us to do now is to make a table and kind
of look at what happens you know to the
left and the right at this point so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to pick some
points like negative 4 negative 2
positive 2 positive 4 okay so let's put
in negative 4 negative 4 would give us
negative 8 over 19 so that's negative 8
19 we put positive 4 and it's gonna be
possible over 16 plus 3 is 19 so it's
positive 8 19 if we put in negative 2 we
get negative 4 over 7 if you put in
positive 2 where you get a positive 4/7
okay so now if we plot these points
let's see what we have so at negative 4
1 2 3 4 negative 8 19 negative 8 19 sin
negative 1/2 okay so it's going to be
basically right here okay just
estimating okay this is a hand a graph
positive 4 1 2 3 4 8 19 it's going to be
a little bit less than 1/2 right there
and then if we put in negative 2
negative 4/7 this is a little bit you
know a little bit more than negative if
you have negative 4/7 is a little bit
greater than well 4/7 is greater than
1/2 so what I mean to say so basically
this is gonna be a little bit lower than
halfway so that's going to be right
about here
okay and then over here at 2 4/7 that's
gonna be little bit more than 1/2 so
it's gonna be little bit more than
halfway like so so if you can see what's
happening here I might have exaggerated
a little bit but the graphs going up and
then it gradually starts to settle back
down as it goes out to the right see
it's approaching that horizontal
asymptote same thing here see it's
crossing the x-axis okay that horizontal
asymptote it dips down but then it
starts to gradually make its way back up
so it's kind of like a s shape I guess
you could say so that's a kind of
interesting graph where it crosses the
horizontal asymptote but as you go to
the right and left end of the graphic
approaches that horizontal asymptote
alright guys for our final problem
number six we have f of x equals x minus
3 divided by x squared minus 4x plus 3
and once again our task is to sketch the
rational function so what we'll be doing
first is attempting to factor the
original function it does appear that
the denominator is factorable that is a
quadratic trinomial and we would be
looking for two factors of three that
would add to give us four well in that
case we can use three and one so that
means that we'll factor this into X
minus three times X minus one as those
are the two fighters that would multiply
to give us positive three and there at
the same time combined to give you a
result of negative four which is your
middle term in the denominator then
you'll want to identify any holes that
you may have now keep in mind that
anytime you have an identical factor in
the numerator and in the denominator
those are gonna be holes within your
graph and as it turns out we can
simplify we can cancel out those X minus
3s that'll leave us with 1 over X minus
1 and then this is not only going to be
our factored form but our reduced form
of the rational function this 1 divided
by X minus 1 when it comes to 5
the point where our hole occurs and set
the fact that that was casted out to
zero so you'll have X minus three equal
to zero
go ahead and add three to both sides of
your equation to find out that x equals
2/3 so it's when x equals 2/3 that
you'll end up having a hole within your
function so remember if you would be
plugging in 3 into the simplified form
of your rational function so as we plug
in 3 into this problem you'll have 1
over 3 minus 1 which gives you 1/2 so
our point where the hole occurs is at 3
1/2 now remember that we'll find the
vertical asymptotes by setting the
remaining factors that are in the
reduced form of your rational function
you'll set those to zero in order to
find the vertical asymptotes so we'll
have X minus one equals zero and then by
adding one of those sides of the
equation you'll have x equals one and
this is going to be your vertical
asymptote read that boxing solo backs up
our reduced form of the rational
function whoa box up the fact that we'll
have a hole at 3 1/2 and that our
vertical asymptote is going to be x
equals 1 will now look for our
horizontal asymptote
now our horses on a slope is going to be
found the same way as before we identify
the degree of the numerator which in
this case is zero because we just have a
constant and the degree of the
denominator remember the degree is the
exponent on your variable X okay so in
the denominator our exponent on the
variable X is 1 so you have a degree of
zero the numerator as degree of 1 in the
denominator
in any time the degree of the numerator
is less than the degree of the
denominator that means that your
horizontal asymptote will be y equals
zero so that's what man y equals zero so
horizontal when it comes to finding the
x intercept you might have one no I'm
not gonna have one because 1 equals 0 is
a contradictory statement that's one and
one denis equals zero so it's not
possible to find your x intercept you'll
normally find your x n sub guys when you
have at least a variable in the
numerator that you can solve for in
order to find the y intercept you find
out what f of 0 is and you can do this
with your simplified form so f of 0
equals to 1 divided by 0 minus 1 which
gives us 1 divided
negative 1 which is negative 1 so as a
point your awareness up is going to be 0
negative 1 red boxes so we have a
horizontal asymptote y equals 0 you will
not have an x intercept and you will
have a y-intercept at 0 negative 1 all
right let's go ahead and try to put
everything together the first thing I'll
probably want to do is set up my
framework starting out with the
asymptotes we know that we're gonna have
a horizontal assets up at y equals 0
that means that the x axis is now
off-limits and then as far as the
vertical asymptotes is concerned you'll
have a vertical a stub at x equals to 1
just like this guys all right now mind
you I did tell you guys earlier that
when you have a rational function in
this form here that parent function that
f of X equals to 1 over X will give you
a graph like this right ok so basically
this says it as X approaches negative
infinity Y will be approaching 0 and as
X approaches positive infinity Y will be
approaching 0 in this case and then the
next thing we'll do we want to find out
as many points as possible we do know
that we have a hole at 3 1/2 so let's
identify that sort at 3 got a hole right
there at 1/2 and then we're going to
want to know values to the left and
right of our vertical asymptote remember
that when x equals to 1 the function is
undefined so that means that I want to
find out values such as 0 or negative 1
and then also 2 & 3 as far as plugging
these values into the reduced form of
our rational function in the word
sketchup' so plugging in 0 of course we
already did that
the answer was negative 1 that's our y
intercept then plugging in negative 1
you'll end up with negative 1/2 as a
result and then plugging in 2 you'll end
up with 1 and then plugging in 3 you'll
end up with 1/2 which is where our hole
is by the way let's make a note of that
okay when X is 3 you'll be at your hole
so let's go ahead and find out 1
point if we plug in for you'll have one
third as a point all right so let's go
ahead and flesh this out guys you're
gonna have the negative one negative one
half so at negative one I'm at negative
one half
that's the point right here then zero
I'm I'm at negative one and then we have
our vertical asymptotes here then at -
I'm at positive one and then at four I'm
at 1/3 which is about right here and
based on our parent function we know
that our end result here is going to be
the following let me grab the mixtures
like this will be approaching our
asymptotes not touching the hole at all
ok and basically having the shape of our
parent function for a rational function
here and that completes problem number
six I appreciate you guys letting me
crash Mario's math tutoring Channel
today and I appreciate you guys for the
opportunity so a great big thank you to
Fort Bend tutoring for working together
with me to produce this video for you go
ahead and subscribe to his channel and
go over to his channel and check out
some of the many math tutoring videos
that he has available for you I hope you
enjoyed this video look forward to
seeing in the next one